[Musique]
il ya quelques années j'étais obèses
j'ai toujours était grosse je me bats
contre mon poids depuis l'enfance et
j'ai rencontré un top professionnels de
santé qui m'ont toujours répéter la même
chose mais madame c'est pas compliqué
manger moins et fait du sport mais c'est
ça j'irai déjà mes pensées évidemment
j'avais pensé
j'avais déjà tout essayé tous les
régimes de la terre les pilules miracles
et les crèmes amincissantes
et croyez moi j'en ai testé des trucs
farfelues j'ai souvent fini entouré de
cellophane avec deux feuilles de salade
en guise de repas et la photo de shakira
accrocheur mon frigo
alors ça marchait attends je perdais du
poids beaucoup parfois jusqu'à ce que je
doive affronter des émotions difficiles
à contrôler stress ou comme cette fois
où suite au deuil d'un être cher
j'ai appris 40 kilos en l'espace de six
mois
et arrive avec les kilos les chèques la
dévalorisation la culpabilité
je me disais à quoi bon continuer
puisque je suis né j'y arriverai jamais
alors la nourriture redevenait ma
meilleure alliée pour mieux oublier
jusqu'au jour où j'ai atteint les 130 kg
j'étais ce qu'on appelle en obésité
morbide morbide
c'est un mot effrayant et pour cause ma
santé a tellement décliné que je suis
passé pas loin de la mort et à ce moment
là un médecin des urgences m'a dit une
phrase que je n'oublierai jamais si vous
perdez pas deux fois
pas très pâle et 30 ans j'avais 22 ans
mais comment faire puisque rien ne
semblait marcher pour moi j'étais seul
mais déterminés à pas me laisser mourir
alors j'ai commencé un immense travail
de recherche
j'ai étudié des centaines d'études sur
l'obésité et la première chose que j'ai
appris c'est que j'étais pas seuls que
ça en fait
l'obésité c'est une maladie reconnue par
l' oms qui touche près d'un milliard de
personnes dans le monde et eux aussi ils
sont en échec
c'est prouvé 85% reprendront tous le
poids perdu et même davantage le fameux
effet yoyo alors je me suis posé cette
question mais pourquoi pourquoi cette
maladie considérée comme un problème de
santé publique majeur
n'at-elle toujours pas trouvé de
solution pour être enrayée pourquoi tant
de personnes dans le monde continuent à
souffrir de leur poids ce que mes
premiers travaux de recherche ont rêvé
l'ont complètement changé ma façon de
voir les choses
j'ai fait une découverte extraordinaire
vous êtes prêts nous avons tous un
cerveau qui fonctionne
alors je sais parfois on peut se poser
la question mais quand même comment j'ai
pu passer à côté de ça pendant tout ce
temps comment toute une partie du corps
médical at il pu occulter cela pendant
toutes ces années
alors c'est vrai que dans la médecine
occidentale on a tendance à se
concentrer sur le traitement de ce qu'on
peut voir les conséquences sans trop
s'intéresser à la cause nous passons à
côté de l'essentiel
notre cerveau construit apprend réagi il
met parfois en place des mécanismes de
défense et c'est lui qui commande à
notre corps tout entier
c'est pour ça que dans toutes les
maladies mais particulièrement dans les
maladies chroniques comme l'obésité
il est primordial de travailler sur les
causes
en prenant en charge les aspects
psychologiques et sociologiques de la
pathologie
convaincu de cette vérité j'ai poursuivi
mon enquête je me suis documenté sur les
thérapies cognitives et comportementales
sur les addictions sur les neurosciences
et sur l'impact des stéréotypes de
beauté des injonctions sociétale à la
minceur
je pouvais plus m'arrêter j'ai même
poussé le bouchon jusqu'à 1 rentrée en
faculté de médecine pour former à la
gestion des troubles du comportement
alimentaire puis dans la préparation
d'une thèse l'aboutissement c'était
incroyable je découvrais un monde génial
et je m'apercevais de combien je m'étais
trompé de la violence à laquelle j'avais
le confronter mon corps et de la façon
inhumaine dont je me traitaient grâce à
mes recherches et commencer à construire
des exercices concrets
un programme pour travailler sur moi
tenez par exemple pour gérer mes
pulsions alimentaires
j'ai eu une mauvaise journée au travail
je me sens pas bien mon boss me mets
beaucoup de pression et je suis débordé
je stresse j'ai qu'une envie c'est de
rentrer à la maison et me jeter sur le
frigo pas parce que j'ai faim mais juste
pour me sentir rempli pour pu sentir
cette sensation qui brûlent à
l'intérieur de moi et étouffer toutes
ces émotions négatives alors je mets en
place cet exercice simple noté ma faim
et identifiés ma vraie fin qu'est ce que
je ressens puis fatigué alors j'ai faim
de sommeil je dois aller me reposer ou
encore je me sens triste
ma vraie fin c'est une 20 de réconfort
je vais plutôt appelé une amie pour
partager ma peine j'apprends à écouter
mes émotions mes ressentis et y répondre
différemment
petit à petit j'ai écrit une méthode en
30 points pour travailler sur l'estimé
de soi la gestion des émotions la
gestion du stress
l'affirmation est toute cette méthode
elle a tellement bien marché que j'ai
perdu 60 kg en deux ans et demi
mais la perte de poids ça a été qu un
dommage collatéral d'un travail beaucoup
plus profond sur la reprogrammation de
mon cerveau mais aussi et surtout
l'amour de moi mais attention je vais
pas vous raconter des salades
je m'estime pas guéri pour autant
l'obésité c'est une maladie chronique
ça fait huit ans maintenant que je me
maintiens et c'est pas facile tous les
jours
il m'arrive encore d'avoir des moments
de doute toujours est il que mon
changement tant sur le plan physique que
psychologique n'a pas échappé à mon
entourage alors des amis qui vivaient la
même chose que moi sont venus me trouver
pour me demander de partager avec elle
ma méthode
alors on a commencé à se regrouper entre
copines pour parler de nos difficultés
nos histoires partager nos états d'âme
et travailler sur ces fameux exercices
au début on était 5
et puis de plus en plus de monde nous a
rejoint
c'est comme ça qu'est née l'association
obèses anonyme
c'est un endroit où j'ai énormément
appris sur moi-même et sur la maladie
mais aussi sur les horreurs que les
autres peuvent nous balancent au visage
d'ailleurs on en a fait un film
s'appelle grosse il parle de nos
histoires de notre maladie des
discriminations et de la dimension
psycho social temps d'oublier
derrière les kilos mais quand on fait
pas des films on est dans la vraie vie
avec les gens qui souffrent et il y en a
beaucoup
de fil en aiguille l'association a
grandi et je recevais des mails des
coups de fil de toute la france pour
nous demander de rejoindre le groupe de
parole malheureusement je pouvais pas me
dédoubler être partout à la fois alors
je me suis creusé la tête dans tous les
sens afin de trouver une solution pour
pouvoir aider tout le monde
assez vite l'idée du digital m'est
apparu oui digitalisées le programme
c'était peut-être ça une partie de la
solution et puis ça répondait à plein de
questions que nous aurons monter les
membres de l'association comme mais
comment avoir un soutien 24 heures sur
24 quand je fais une crise ou encore
mais comment faire pour être autonome
sans guide son soutien au quotidien de
chez moi ou oui mais je te rends compte
j'ai six mois d'attentes entre deux
rendez-vous médicaux comment je fais
entre temps en plus de répondre à toutes
ces problématiques
une application permet de mettre sous
format digital
tous les contenus de nos réunions pour
les avoir apporté
mains dans son téléphone et en
complément d'un projet de soins avec une
vraie équipe médicale pluridisciplinaire
sur le terrain le digital permet
d'accéder à des outils pédagogiques pour
devenir acteur de sa prise en charge
alors on s'y est mis à plusieurs avec
une équipe formidable de personnes qui
eux aussi ont connu l'obésité avec des
médecins des chercheurs des psychologues
des nutritionnistes qui croit au pouvoir
du patient avec cette équipe de
passionnés de tous horizons a construit
cette fameuse application
obg talent ensemble on s'est demandé
comment on pourrait vraiment faire
changer les choses
j'ai repensé à mes années de lutte et je
me suis posé cette question
de quoi j'aurais vraiment et besoins à
l'époque où je me suis sentie si seul
qu'est ce qui m'aurait vraiment aidé
fait du bien de façon concrète la
première chose à laquelle j'ai pensé ce
sont toutes ces personnes en situation
de précarité les plus touchées par
l'obésité qui n'ont même pas les moyens
de se payer un suivi médical des sens
alors on est partis en premier lieu à la
recherche de financement est prise en
charge par les systèmes de soins puis on
a construit les supports les contenus
comme le visiter est une maladie
multifactorielle
on a souhaité proposer quelque chose de
global et ça tombe plutôt bien les
nouvelles technologies elle regorge
d'outils incroyable comme un chat botté
pour gérer les crises du comportement
alimentaire en temps réel de la thérapie
interactive pour travailler sur soi et
déconstruire tous les schémas qui mène à
l'obésité un jeu vidéo sérieux pour
apprendre à manger sans avoir à compter
toutes les calories
l'idée c'est que même un enfant puisse
le faire des circuits d'activités
physiques adaptées à la morphologie de
l'obèse et sécurisée grâce à des
systèmes de caméra intelligente
ou encore un carnet de bord connecter
avec son médecin bien utiliser les
nouvelles que les nouvelles technologies
peuvent construire des ponts entre les
patients et les soignants et faciliter
la diffusion des connaissances mais
c'est aussi un beau pied de nez à tous
le monde digital qui peut aussi parfois
nous faire tant de mal en nous balançant
toujours plus de modèle de perfection au
visage d'information fausse ou solution
miracle car oui j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle
y a pas de solution miracle
la solution elle est en vous et vous
êtes les seuls à pouvoir faire le choix
de vous en sortir
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que vous
pouvez choisir de reprendre le pouvoir
choisir de vous aimer choisir de vous
relever choisir de continuer à avancer
une citation de socrate qui dit la chute
n'est pas un échec
l'échec c'est de rester là on est tombé
alors relevé vous vous n'êtes plus seuls
merci
[Applaudissements]